[Música]
delicada situación sanitaria en francia
por cuenta de la pandemia
el presidente de manuel macro en estudia
nuevas restricciones los pacientes en
ucis superan los cinco mil por su parte
la alcaldesa de parís y el presidente de
la federación de hospitales de francia
surgieron al gobierno para cerrar las
escuelas y frenar la rápida expansión
del virus
en plena semana santa nueva tregua el
avance de una nueva oleada de muertes y
contagios en américa latina brasil
rompió nuevamente un récord de
fallecidos en 24 horas y suma 13 días
con un promedio por encima de los 1000
muertos por día los repuntes también
afectan a argentina chile ecuador y
colombia
en mianmar continúan las advertencias de
grupos étnicos armados del país a la
junta militar gobernante para que paren
los asesinatos a civiles en las
protestas la unión nacional karen el
ejercito étnico más antiguo prometió
defender su territorio mientras tanto
españa eeuu y alemania de [__] a sus
ciudadanos salir de este país
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 su revelan como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en francia ante las cifras en alza de
los casos de kobe 19 el colapso de las
ucis y las críticas al gobierno por la
estrategia en el manejo de la pandemia
el presidente de manera macrón anunciará
a las 8 de la noche hora local nuevas
medidas para frenar el avance del virus
las unidades de cuidados intensivos
especialmente las de la región de parís
ya están al nivel de ocupación superior
al 100 por ciento con ello son numerosas
las voces que piden la implantación de
un confinamiento estricto ante el riesgo
de un colapso
paciente tras paciente este doctor de
cuidados intensivos ve como su unidad
alcanza su tope de capacidad en este
hospital al norte de parís están
llegando más personas enfermas de las
que son dadas de alta
tuvimos que abrir 8 camas extra para
cuidados intensivos de nuestros 26 camas
y 20 son para pacientes
todas las ucis de la región de parís se
están acercando al punto de saturación y
esto podría ser sólo el comienzo las
proyecciones de los hospitales públicos
de la región están alertando de un
empeoramiento en las próximas semanas en
torno a 1500 pacientes kobe se
encuentran en estos momentos en cuidados
intensivos solamente en la región con
ello el país superó la barrera de los
5.000 pacientes uci una cifra que se
sitúa por encima del pico alcanzado
durante la segunda ola de mediados de
noviembre
este profesor afirma que el tiempo de
espera se acabó y se necesita de manera
inmediata un confinamiento estricto
sí sí instauramos un confinamiento
estricto necesitamos una campaña seria
de concienciación lo primero es que esto
no durará meses sino semanas si nos
unimos y empujamos todos juntos lo
superaremos
woods a clarín ya los funcionarios de
hospitales han basado sus proyecciones
en una perspectiva pesimista creen que
el confinamiento parcial actual tendrá
poco efecto el presidente francés
emmanuel macon hizo lo que muchos
consideran una apuesta arriesgada al
ignorar la recomendación de su consejo
científico y no imponer un confinamiento
estricto en enero citando la salud
mental de los estudiantes y la maltrecha
economía del país la llegada de nuevas y
más contagiosas variantes del virus ha
subido a las apuestas más temprano
nuestra periodista natalia ruiz desde
parís nos explicó cuáles son las
hipótesis que se tienen de las medidas
que podría tomar el presidente de manuel
macrón esta noche veamos
cuando el presidente masón se ha
dirigido a los franceses a lo largo de
esta pandemia lo ha hecho en momentos
bastante críticos y bastante claves se
tienen tres hipótesis sobre la mesa por
una parte dejar las cosas así como están
con el toque de queda en todo el
territorio y los 19 departamentos que
por ahora están confinados aunque una
manera un confinamiento ligero pero
repartir mejor los pacientes en las
unidades de reanimación esto sin el aval
de las familias como viene siendo hasta
ahora la otra hipótesis es el cierre de
escuelas y colegios algo que el gobierno
ha querido evitar y lo ha venido
evitando incluso durante el segundo
confinamiento a finales del año pasado
las escuelas permanecieron abiertas y
por último pues es la decisión más
dolorosa digamos o más difícil que
volvería a ser un confinamiento estricto
así como el que se decretó en la
primavera pasada pero que quizás
solamente se aplicaría a los 19
departamentos donde la situación
actualmente es crítica y el avance de la
pandemia en américa latina' no ha
frenado durante la semana santa la
región está inmersa en una virulenta ola
de contagios y fallecidos lidera una vez
más brasil con su cifra más alta de
muerte
registrada en 24 horas un repunte que
también preocupa en argentina chile y
ecuador
después de más de un año de pandemia
brasil sigue registrando cifras inéditas
este martes tuvo el día más mortal por
kobe 19 con 3 mil 780 fallecidos en 24
horas una situación de salud crítica que
llega a lo económico con cada vez más
personas con dificultades para comer
mire esta situación si no fuera por la
iglesia repartiendo esta comida no sé
dónde comería donde no tengo dinero
el colapso también llega a chile con
hospitales desbordados como en
valparaíso en el hospital van buren
tuvieron que recurrir a dos morgues
móviles y eso pese a que la práctica
totalidad del país está confinada y ya
hay más del 35 por ciento de los
chilenos vacunados que da la sensación
de que
como se contó que había un éxito muy
importante en la campaña alguna acción
la gente se conoció en argentina para
evitar el colapso de sus vecinos este
martes se cerraron fronteras terrestres
el día en el que se superaron los 14 mil
casos en 24 horas una cifra no vista
desde octubre además siguen restringidos
los vuelos internacionales con méxico
chile y brasil
el repunte llega a ecuador con unidades
de cuidados intensivos saturadas y con
quito y guayaquil aplicando
restricciones esta última tendrá un
horario elaborada hasta las 4 de la
tarde mientras que la capital restringe
la movilidad desde las 10 de la noche a
las 6 de la mañana será una semana santa
diferente en el transcurso de estos días
tenemos una alta ocupación en las camas
del sistema hospitalario de quito pese a
que los contagios también suben en
colombia' con casi 8.000 casos en 24
horas la cifra del día es que se
alcanzaron las 2 millones de dosis
administradas un número que esperan que
suba a 3 millones para el 17 de abril
vamos hasta centroamérica donde una
nueva caravana de cientos de migrantes
ayuda hace dos días de la ciudad de san
pedro sula en honduras rumbo a eeuu en
busca de asilo y pese a las advertencias
de cierre de la frontera anunciado por
el gobierno de joe vayan entre los
caminantes hay también menores de edad y
mujeres embarazadas
ese grupo de centroamericanos huyen de
sus países debido a las pocas
oportunidades en medio de una aguda
crisis sanitaria
de la pandemia de hoy 19 para entender
un poco más esta crisis migratoria que
afecta mayor medida a los menores de
edad salud en este momento a jaime
flórez coordinador del observatorio de
los derechos de niñez en casa alianza
honduras gracias por estar con nosotros
en france 24 señor flores muy buen día a
pesar de esta difícil situación de los
menores en centros de atención al pasar
la frontera a eeuu y el llamado de las
autoridades estadounidenses a los
migrantes de no pasar a su territorio
porque se sigue presentando esta
situación y cómo afecta emocionalmente a
los menores ser separados de su familia
muy buenos días es un gusto estar con
sol de audiencia al hablar aquí
porque se van los niños las niñas
hondureña se van por dos razones
principalmente anteriormente los niños
se iban y la niñez se iba por la reunión
reunificación familiar y por este una
movilidad económica en este caso la
niñez hondureña está huyendo de la
violencia que existe en el país
actualmente en las principales 22
ciudades del país 500 barrios y colonias
se encuentran en poder del crimen
organizado hay una total ausencia de
estado entonces más que crisis
migratoria deberíamos hablar de crisis
de desplazamiento interno y externo
desplazamiento forzado en los últimos 10
años en los últimos 10 años 58 mil 500
hogares han sido desplazados de estos
cuatro un 40% son niños y niñas la he
para esto se está grabando cada día más
en el país y por ende vamos
vamos a ver un mayor flujo de gente
huyendo de honduras no es propiamente
hablar solo inmigración tenemos que
hablar de desplazamiento forzado por
violencia sin las consecuencias que
tiene que ocasionen los niños son
múltiples principalmente el ser
separados por su familia este y los
daños emocionales son múltiples
principalmente hemos atendido niños en
casa alianza con problemas de ansiedad
con problemas de miedo y los daños
físicos en algunos casos son gasto
irreversible lamentable lo que nos está
contando y le pregunto entonces señor
flores desde su organización qué tipo de
ayudas ofrecen a los menores de edad y
también a sus familias bueno en la
organización en la que nosotros
trabajamos te ofrece
albert es permanente que hay un programa
presidencial atención a las familias y
tenemos un programa especialmente en san
pedro sula en el departamento de cortés
para atender a la niñez y a familias
desplazadas por la violencia este este
fenómeno está creciendo y es un fenómeno
que no se le pone la atención debida el
gobierno actualmente habla de que de que
247 mil familias han sido desplazadas
por violencia las organizaciones de la
sociedad civil y diversas organizaciones
que trabajan en este tema hablan de
medio millón de personas al menos ahora
en su opinión que tiene que ocurrir en
los países del triángulo norte para que
esta situación se regularizó un poco y
dejemos de ver esta huida y el
desplazamiento interno también como
usted nos está comentando
miren en primer lugar el término
triángulo norte es un término que no me
gusta usar porque es el término que nos
ha puesto eeuu y con eso noches en matiz
a cada país que se estigmatiza es un
país problemático para ellos yo hablo de
los países del norte de centroamérica en
este caso que se debe hacer es cumplir
los estados deben cumplir y garantizar
los derechos de la niñez honduras por
ejemplo es el país que más viola los
derechos de las niñas y niños
actualmente son 800.000 niños este están
recibiendo cobertura educativa de 3.000
de 3 millones del tiempo 2000 que la
necesitan y estos 800.000 sólo 350.000
aprobaron su año su año lectivo
posteriormente en la última en la última
década han sido asesinados más de 300 de
13.500 niños niñas en el país por el
escriba hemos realizado entonces un país
que no puede garantizar los derechos de
las niñas este va a tener y va a seguir
profundizándose esta problemática
buscar mejores oportunidades o
garantizar su vida en otros territorios
señor flores gracias por su tiempo por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
lamentable la situación que se vive con
la niñez en honduras y también los
países de centroamérica seguimos también
en honduras porque toni hernández es
hermano del presidente hondureño juan
orlando hernández fue sentenciado a
cadena perpetua en eeuu por tráfico de
drogas según la fiscalía de la unión
americana
este es un tráfico de drogas patrocinado
por el estado salpicando así al
presidente juan orlando hernández y es
que no es la primera vez que el
mandatario se ve implicado en
señalamientos por tráfico de
estupefacientes en una acusación formal
en el caso del narcotraficante hondureño
giovanni fuentes los fiscales dijeron
que hernández quien ha sido presidente
desde el año 2014 utilizó a oficiales de
orden público y también militares para
proteger a estos narcotraficantes
se recrudece el conflicto en mianmar
después de dos meses de protestas contra
la junta militar varios grupos étnicos
armados que en su momento habían pactado
un alto el fuego con el gobierno estaban
cada vez más cerca de unirse a esta
lucha contra el ejército las fuerzas
armadas bombardearon la región karen en
la frontera con tailandia desplazando a
unas 3.000 personas y provocando la
oposición de la posición de una de las
guerrillas más antiguas del país
mientras tanto la líder depuesto
jim pudo comunicarse con uno de sus
abogados más romeros nos cuenta más
desde que el ejército tomó el poder el 1
de febrero nadie había visto aún san suu
kyi la líder elegida democráticamente en
mianmar ahora uno de sus abogados tiene
buenas noticias si te pidió y exigió una
reunión privada como abogada y acusada
con su abogado defensor
por lo que vi en la pantalla del vídeo
and sun such y parecía gozar de buena
salud
las protestas contra la junta militar
que la depuso se mantienen en varias
ciudades del país a pesar de que según
organizaciones de derechos humanos más
de 500 civiles han muerto durante las
manifestaciones una cifra que no deja de
aumentar
igual que la tensión en mianmar
recientemente la presión del ejército
salió de las ciudades para dirigirse
hacia las fronteras del país donde
varios grupos étnicos armados operan
desde hace años en la frontera con
tailandia los ataques desplazaron a unas
3.000 personas de la etnia karen la
unión nacional karen que tiene una
facción armada en la región ya aseguró
que se está preparando para responder a
la ofensiva militar para defender su
territorio y otros tres grupos rebeldes
advirtieron a la junta que romperán el
alto al fuego pactado con el gobierno y
se unirán a las protestas si la
violencia contra los civiles persiste
si no se detienen y continúan matando a
la gente cooperaremos con los
manifestantes y lucharemos así el
conflicto en mianmar se acerca cada vez
más a una guerra civil
ante el recrudecimiento de la violencia
tanto españa como eeuu pidieron a sus
ciudadanos que abandonen el territorio
y esta manera llegamos al final de la
informativa en france24 continua con
nosotros son muy buen día
[Música]